it was 6:30 in the morning and the
narrow alleys of elamari refugee camp
were still
quiet Israeli soldiers lined up and made
their way to the home of samur bedra his
family was jolted out of bed when they
kicked open the front door they were
after samar's two eldest
Sons I asked why they were doing this
and they said we're at War when I asked
if I could give my sons their jackets
it's cold outside the officer in charge
told me your children shouldn't be
alive this is the moment they were LED
away the family doesn't know where they
were taken to more than 60 Palestinians
were detained in less than 12 hours
across the occupied West
Bank this video filmed by a soldier
shows him taunting the young man taken
away the number of daily detentions has
tripled over the past week that's that's
according to the Palestinian prisoner
Society but there's also another concern
that those already held in Israeli jails
are coming under duress by law Israel is
obliged to respond to lawyers who ask
about the whereabouts of a detin that
hasn't happened since the outbreak of
this war according to hoked an Israeli
Human Rights group usually we are
receiving 100 phone calls a week now we
are receiving 100 phone calls a day
we have written urgently to Israel's
attorney general to say uh you know you
cannot deny prisoners access to their
lawyers there are reports but we cannot
confirm about uh violence about some
punishments when s Mahammad last spoke
to her husband he told her that things
have changed inside the jail ever since
hamas's attack on
Israel he told me that this this could
be the last time we speak for a while he
said that the prison Authority has
imposed punishments on them confiscating
belongings water is available for an
hour per day electricity is cut off
during the day her husband has been held
for more than a year without charges
it's not the first time her young son
has only seen his father for 3 months
during his three years of life as Israel
prepares for a possible ground offensive
in Gaza Palestinians else where fear its
effects will increasingly impact them
ABD Hamid Al jazer
ramala